I woke up one morning to a text from
matpat asking if I would be interested
in doing some content with him I'm not
going to lie I 100% thought it was a
scam account at first see I have a teeny
tiny following on Twitter like some
punctuation marks are bigger than my
following on Twitter but I am just big
enough to have some scam Bots slide up
in my DM sometimes and that's exactly
what I thought that text was I didn't
even believe the blue verified check
mark by his name this is back when that
actually meant something by the way but
when I clicked on his profile and behold
it took me to the Bonafide at matpat GT
Twitter page with 5 million followers
and it said that it was following me
hold
up okay he's he's still following me so
we're good he reached out to me because
of a video that I had made you see I'm a
huge fan of video games and you know I'm
something of a theorist myself but see
at the time historically I had only made
those kinds of videos on the Nintendo
games never about anything Five Nights
at Freddy's but I was very interested
I had always been a fan of the franchise
I had always followed Matt Pat's Game
Theory videos about it and once security
breach came out man lore was right for
the picking so I thought to myself hey
why don't I try my hand at making a
theory about Five Nights at Freddy's you
know because I'm crazy and I was very
nervous about tackling the libraries
worth of lore that you have to in order
to theorize in that Community but I did
what I always do and just jumped in head
first to my surprise I was actually met
with a pretty warm welome from the
members of the FNAF community and before
I knew it I was uploading a second
theory video also covering security
breach and it was met with an even more
positive reaction from the members of
the theorizing community but about 2
weeks later this is where things got
interesting see in that video I had made
a connection between Cassidy the
protagonist of the princess Quest arcade
game in security breach and golden
Freddy and I uploaded that video on
January 23rd well on February 5th Matt
pad uploaded his video covering the the
same thing our research had led us to
the same conclusion and when I watched
that video man that made me more excited
than a drug addict in a Walgreens my
nervousness about jumping head first
into the fandom was washed away almost
entirely I mean if me a newbie to the
franchise could make a theory that the
likes of Matthew pathu and his team had
ordained as being legitimate then that's
a good sign right so I made a video
about just that praising the performance
and accuracy of the Five Nights at
Freddy's video on my channel and my
point with that video was to at least
try to go some of the viewers that exist
in this torrential waterf flow of Five
Nights at Freddy's viewers on YouTube to
my channel which was largely not really
successful but it was successful in
attracting the attention of one person
in particular yeah him I never in one
million years thought that Matt Pat
himself would see that video but he did
and the next thing you know I'm waking
up one morning 11 days later and boom
there's the text on my phone hey Jordan
my name is Matt Pat from the theorist
channels on
YouTube he was putting together a live
stream that he wanted the top five
nights at Freddy's theorist creators on
the scene to be a part of and for some
reason he thought that I would be a good
fit he said that because we had come to
the same conclusion that was a very good
sign and of course I accepted I mean
yeah I was new to the community but it's
Matt Pat from Game Theory
I replied to his message with a very
long half response half fan letter
message well if or being honest it's
probably 20% of response and 80% just
fan mail which I still kind of cringe
over when I remember it but he was very
generous and responded anyway with an
actual thought out message everything
looked great so he emailed me personally
and then handed me off to his team
personally for some Logistics that we
had to get straightened out before the
stream at the the whole time I was just
so impressed with how Hands-On he was
with communication I mean I am 1
1,000th the size that he is as a Creator
and even I find it hard to respond to
messages due to just the number of them
that I receive but he responded to
me I didn't hear from him again until
the day of the stream and when I did
join that chat room oh boy was I nervous
I mean there I was me bandit in this
room with Doo and super horror bro and
FNAF and tetrabit gaming and Tom and Dan
and these are all pillars of the Five
Nights at Freddy's Community actually
they're pillars of YouTube gaming as a
whole what was I doing there but then
about an hour before the stream was
supposed to start Matt Pat himself
joined early just to chat with us just
to get to know us and then I was
reminded why I was there I was there
because he wanted me to be there also by
the way huge congratulations to Tom he's
going to be the next game theory host so
we're all very excited to see what
happens with that but anyway in the
Stream Matt Pat knew Doo personally and
knew of super horror bro but yet still
divided his attention equally to
everybody he even talked to me quite a
bit and asked me about why my name was
mass Nintendo Bandit and how I felt
about moving away from Nintendo and fun
fact that's actually what inspired me to
finally go ahead and change my name to
Bandit games not because he was being
condescending or anything like that but
because it just made me realize that
everybody's going to have to get over my
name if I am to incorporate more than
just Nintendo content regardless I
continued to be absolutely impressed by
his ability to talk to everybody like
they had 100% of his concentration like
you were just having a genuine
conversation no matter who you were the
stream went well and the rest is history
and I hadn't heard from him again and
until his goodbye internet video 2 days
ago announcing his retirement from the
theorist channels on YouTube and that
video
is I mean it's it's emotional it's sad
and the thing is when I watched that
video knowing what I know about matpat
what I personally know about matpat from
my personal experiences with
him I have no doubt that he was 100%
genuine when he told us that we were
more than just numbers to him I sent him
another message after I had watch watch
that video and after I saw his tweet
about crying all over again reading your
messages this tweet has hundreds of
thousands of likes tens of thousands of
reposts and millions of views I mean do
you have any idea how many messages this
man must have been bombarded with every
minute I knew this but just decided to
send him a little bit of warmth anyway
just from me to him on the off notion
that he may one day stumble across it
but a few hours later he replied you
realize his video was and still is the
number one trending video on all of
YouTube mattad himself was trending as a
topic across all of Twitter across the
entire internet and like he said in the
video this is all in addition to the
fact that he's so busy he barely sleeps
and he responded to
me and it wasn't just some generic hey
thanks man message it was legitimately
thought out he remembered
me he said was crazy that it had already
been 2 years since that stream that time
flies and that he hoped I had been
well I made this video to let everyone
know that in light of his recent
decision to step down from hosting game
theory he is one of the most real and
down-to-earth people I've ever met much
less online much less as a content
creator online a celebrity content
creator at that and mat pad or team if
you so happen to stumble across this
video I just want to say thank you to
you from the bottom of my heart and on
behalf of every view I've ever gotten on
this channel for inspiring the content
that I make and for being a friend and
to those of you watching thank you for
watching I just wanted to make a little
tribute to Matt Pat for everything that
he has done for us as a community I know
I normally ask you to comment something
below related to video games so today
I'm going to ask you to comment below on
what your favorite theory of Matt Pats
was be it Five Nights at Freddy's or not
that's all I had to say about it so I'll
see you guys next time this is Bandit
signing out
[Music]
[Applause]
peace